ANNOUNCER: Setting a new
world record of 2:22:43,
Joan Benoit moves women's
marathoning to the next level.
JOAN BENOIT SAMUELSON: Can
anybody run at any age?
Yes, and that's why
I'm still running well
into my sixth decade.
This class is for
runners, aspiring runners,
and for people who just have a
general interest in our sport.
I'm going to talk
about technique,
stretching and strengthening
exercises, and the importance
of setting goals.
Running should be something that
you look forward to every day
however many times you're
getting out there to run.
The most important things are
finding the proper footwear,
making it fun,
making it purposeful,
and making it something
that fits your lifestyle.
One tip for new
runners is to think
about your running in minutes
as opposed to distance.
And whether it's 15 minutes
a day or every other day,
the fact of the matter
is that you're doing it.
There weren't many sports
available to young girls when
I was growing up because
Title IX legislation hadn't
been enacted into law.
Eventually it passed
in 1972, and that's
when I discovered that I had
a real passion for running.
And I often asked myself
if Title IX hadn't passed,
what would I be doing today?
It's up to you to discover
how far the journey of running
is going to take you.
And if you follow the
lessons in my class,
you will have running
as part of your life
for a long, long time.
I'm Joan Benoit Samuelson,
and this is MasterClass.